hi everyone in a previous video I looked
through this exam here which is the 2018
je e mein exam and I just had a little
look through and showed you I guess what
the syllabus would involve if you were
studying for an exam like this today I'm
going to take the same exam and solve
three of the problems and depth so it's
going to be the first three problems
from the physics section and this is for
anyone who was still a bit more curious
and wanted to see what solving these
problems is actually like rather than
just seeing what the topics are I'm
recording this commentary after I've
already solved the problems and watching
back the footage of how I solved it this
is because I only have one tripod and
also I think this way will help me to
stay kind of concise in my explanations
the first question here is about
collisions and I'll read it out it is
found that if a neutron suffers an
elastic collinear collision with
deuterium at rest
fractional loss of its energy is P D
while for it's similar collision with
carbon nucleus at rest the fractional
loss of energy is PC so we're being
asked to find the values of P D and P C
so we need to know how much energy is
being lost by this neutron through these
two different collisions now I'm trying
to solve these problems with minimal
memorization so sometimes when you look
at these solutions to these je e exams
it seems like if you had memorized a
certain step and it's kind of a shortcut
to solving the problem like maybe you
know stuff already about elastic
collisions and you've done so many of
these problems you know how they sort of
go but without trying to memorize too
much at all let's just go back to the
basics what we will need to know is that
the mass of deuterium will be twice as
much as the mass of just the single
Neutron because deuterium has one proton
and one Neutron and then when we get to
working with carbon its mass will be 12
times the mass of the neutron because
carbons atomic number is 6 so it's got
six protons six neutrons we'll need to
know that an elastic collision
that kinetic energy is being conserved
and that means that after the collision
our two masses are not sticking together
what we can do is write down what the
kinetic energy is going to be on both
sides so before and after the collision
and we know it's conserved so we can put
an equal sign in the middle there if you
cancel out the common terms which is 1/2
m in this case you get v1 squared is
equal to v2 squared plus 2 V 3 squared
so I'm rewriting this equation in terms
of V 3 and then I'm recognizing that V 1
squared minus V 2 squared can be
expanded out in the into these two
brackets V 1 minus V 2 and V 1 plus V 2
that's going to help us combine it with
an equation that we'll find soon that
was all force conserving kinetic energy
now the other thing that's being
conserved here is momentum so we can
write out that in V 1 is equal to em V 2
plus 2 MV 3 that's just conservation
there
then again canceling common terms we can
get V 1 is equal to V 2 plus 2 V 3 we've
got two different equations at this
point but three unknowns so I'm going to
do simultaneous equations and try and
sub in what we found from is considering
momentum into what we were dealing with
before so I'm basically just rearranging
the formulas so that I can sub them in
nicely so doing that allows us to cancel
some terms and we end up with V 1 plus V
2 is equal to V 3 but if we go back and
rearrange what we had before V 3 is
nothing but V 1 minus V 2 over 2 so we
can get rid of V 3 entirely and just
have our equations in terms of V 1 and V
2 this is good because being able to
relate V 1 to V 2 will help us find what
we really want to know which is the
fractional loss of energy finding that
fractional loss of energy remember this
is just
for the neutron we will take the
neutrons kinetic energy before subtract
off the neutrons kinetic energy after
and divide it all by the neutrons
kinetic energy before so kinetic energy
1/2 MV squared and actually writing that
out and canceling those common terms of
1/2 M we get V 1 squared minus V 2
squared over V 1 squared giving us what
we want to find now just sub in our
relation between V 1 and V 2 do a little
bit of arithmetic here and we get that
the final answer is 8 over 9 that's
pretty good so now we actually need to
do all that again for a collision with
carbon the only thing that's going to
change that the carbon is now 12 times
the mass of the neutron so we can might
be able to go a bit faster because
they're doing it again in this example
in my diagram I'm assuming that the
neutron and the carbon move off together
in the same direction
I guess v2 could also go backwards the
neutron could have bounced off and been
going in the opposite direction I worked
through the math was that with that as
well and it doesn't matter whether it
bounces off or goes forward because you
end up squaring the velocity and the
final terms really the absolute value of
that velocity is all that matters there
so again looking at kinetic energy first
and we can jump some of the steps that
we were doing on the previous example to
get V 1 squared equals V 2 squared plus
12 V 3 squared this time and just
rearranging it in a similar way so that
we can cancel some terms again
conserving momentum we end up that v1 is
equal to v2 plus 12 v3 rearranged that
sub it into our kinetic energy equation
we end up with V 1 plus V 2 is equal to
V 3 but the 3 is nothing but V 1 minus V
2 over 12 so we can get rid of v3
entirely get an expression that just
relates V 1 and V 2 then our frictional
loss of energy
very similar thing but now we're subbing
in - 13 / 11 V - as being our value of
v1 and this algebra gets a little bit
more tricky but we end up doing some
fractions we get 48 over 169 as our
fraction there now because the question
is asking for this in terms of decimals
which makes it harder we have to work
that out as a decimal and that will be
0.28 to two decimal places so we need to
go and find the other one decimals - and
that would be zero point eight nine so
then we just need to look at our answers
we have zero point eight nine for the
first one point two eight for the second
one and that gives us the third option
as being correct there our second
question is about molecules bouncing off
a wall and what pressure that's going to
exert on the wall so we have the mass of
a hydrogen molecule is three point three
two times ten to the minus 27 kg if 10
to the 23 hydrogen molecules strike per
second a fixed wall of area two
centimeters squared at an angle of 45
degrees to the normal and rebound
elastically with a speed of 10 to the 3
meters per second then the pressure on
the wall is merely and were asked to
find that value so the basic ideas here
are going to be change in momentum and
working out pressure this is a pretty
easy one to remember pressure as force
over area and in terms of like impulse
force well force is going to be the
change in momentum over the change in
time and if we're dealing with constant
mass which I assume these molecules are
then that's going to come down to mass
times change in velocity over a change
in time starting off just considering a
single molecule we can draw a diagram
we're coming in at an angle losing all
of that momentum and then leaving in the
opposite direction with that momentum
again so because we're being asked about
the pressure that's it exerted on the
wall all we really care about here is
the
horizontal component of what's going on
to the horizontal component of the
change in momentum or the change in
velocity to work out that horizontal
component which I'm calling VH we can do
V one which has our initial velocity
times the sine of 45 that's the same as
doing it the one divided by the square
root of two now because we need to work
out the final velocity in the horizontal
direction we're actually going to do two
times that amount because we're losing
at all getting and gaining it all again
so our change in momentum is going to be
two times that value putting that into
our formula for force we get this and
remember that two over the square root
of 2 is just equal to square root two
and the time that this is going on over
is just one second so we've got a 1 on
the bottom there yeah that was for one
molecule and for n molecules times it by
n that gives us our total force on the
wall then define the total pressure on
that wall we want to divide it by our
area which was 2 centimeters squared so
just plug in all of our values here most
of working this out comes to looking at
our like exponents so we have 10 to the
23 a 10 to the 3 that would be 10 to the
26 we've got a minus 27 so we'd have a
total of 10 to the minus 1 on the top
we've got a 10 to the minus 4 on the
bottom minus 1 minus negative 4 we're
going to end up with 10 to the positive
3 as being the exponent on our answer
and then working out the rest of it in
decimals here it gives us our final
answer which corresponds to option
number three on our exam our last
question now number three we've got a
solid sphere of radius R made of a soft
material of bulk modulus K is surrounded
by a liquid in a cylindrical container a
massless piston of area a floats on the
surface of the liquid covering the
entire cross-section of the cylindrical
container
when a mass M is placed on the surface
of the piston to compress the liquid the
fractional decrement in the radius of
the sphere D R over R is what so
essentially we've got a sphere in a
container and it's being squashed so a
bulk modulus which I think is the only
thing you'll need to know to get started
here is that a bulk modulus is the
change in pressure over like the
fractional change in volume so I've
written the formula here and we're going
to want the I guess absolute value of it
we also need to know the volume of the
sphere here so 4/3 PI R cubed now what
we want is D R over R which is relating
to our radius and that little fraction
there it looks like we're going to need
to differentiate to get there because
that little D R is really indicating
that there's some calculus going on some
infinitesimal change so what we can
start with is by differentiating our
equation for the volume and we can do
that with respect to the radius so we
can find DV d R as being 4 PI R squared
notice that that is the surface area of
a sphere so actually that makes sense
now we've kind of got a DV in our
formula for the bulk modulus so if we
have a look at that and take inspiration
from there and do a DV over V we can
cancel out quite a few terms actually
and we can get left with a formula that
has an R and a d R in it now that's
pretty close to what we want so if we
rearrange for that we end up getting DV
over 3v and if we rearrange our formula
for bulk modulus in terms of the change
in volume over volume that would be
equal to the change in pressure over the
modulus itself so we have enough we need
to be able to sub things and so pressure
is force over area our change in
pressure is going to be coming from our
masse that we've been putting on this so
M times G for our force over the area a
of that piston and they've given it to
us that the bulk modulus is K meaning
that all this comes to be mg over three
ka and that is one of our answers so
that's very nice I hope that gave you
some more insight into solving these
problems from my understanding you don't
get calculators in this exam correct me
if I'm wrong but if you don't get
calculators actually that makes some of
those last steps very difficult those
converting fractions to decimals and
working out those final decimal answers
so congrats to anyone who can do that
and good luck to anyone who's preparing
for exams like this thanks for watching
you